ていません
[音楽]
をきちんと見在住の木村ですよろしくお願いします
ではまず最初にあの動画を見てもらいたいと思います
ええええええ
[音楽]
done
今観ていただいたのがあの宮崎県ならではの天日干し大根を作っている大根やぐら
それとあの木で作っているぬか漬けの風景です
えっとこちらに移っていうのがうちの製品なんですけども
えっ短いものでも2ヶ月から3ヶ月
長いものは3年から5年くらいぬか漬け
して
熟成発酵させてから製品にしています
ちなみにここに写っているのはすべて無着色の
味噌を使ったり醤油を使ったり熟成時間が長かったりしてこんな色が
色々な色が出ます
8漬物はへ
日本の漬物の始まりはへ
海辺の近くにや小夜子を備えて置いておいたら
いつまでも腐らずに
長期間保存ができ
で食べてみたらとても美味しかったとそれが始まりだと言われています
その後海水に野菜をつけて
どうして保存することで始まったのがまあ日本の漬物と言われてて
漬物は保存食というイメージが昔からあると思います
漬物の原理はですねまぁこんな感じです
水分を
余分な水分を抜いて
腐りにくく
することそして熟成することで甘みが増す
できたのが宮崎県は大根やぐらで天日で干す
皆さんもご存じだと思うんですけど胆振学校
は外で干せないので家の中で教えたら胆振の香りがついたと
それをぬか漬けにしたものがゆっくり格好
ですからあの漬物すぐ地域性があって
それぞれの
お漬物には
地域の
関係がすごくあると思い
えっと漬物の種類はですね皆さん色々ご存知だと思いますけど
上野醤油漬味噌漬とかありますが
たくあん漬けはぬか漬け類の一種になります
つまり
たくあん漬けは1回ぬかに漬けたものの
で師範に言われている白いものというのはあれは仕様だったり消費で付けた塾生が
あまりされてない
仕様付とか市長に付けと言われるものになります
漬物はですね保存食品というものから
へ
エンドが2%から5%の定員になり
長期熟成するものから短期で出来上がる
浅漬けみたいなものになってきました
つまり漬物は今保存食から
サラダ感覚なまあどちらかつで野菜に近い
漬物というよりかは野菜に近い食べ物になってきました
そこでへ
言えば時代
時代も変わりましたのでまあここ
提案したいのがぬか漬けです
皆さんの家でぬか漬けされている方います
を期待以上に何
人がいて嬉しいです
あの今日はですねちょっと六門ケアぬか床を家の持ってきました
もしよかったらあの
回してもらって匂い嗅いでもらうと
あの島でこの中に今野菜は何も入ってないぬか床だけです
で漬物まぬか漬けにするとですね
誰でも簡単にぬか床に入れればできます
と
8今日はですねちょっと持ってきたのが
これキャベツなんですがこれで200g
で1日に食べる野菜の量は350g と言われています
だからこれの
約2倍ぐらいに朝馬に食べてくださいということなんですけど
漬物に今日朝塩漬けしたものがこれです
同じかさです
これぐらいになります
ですからあの野菜を効率よく摂取できる月てものでありまたあの
ぬか漬けにするは乳酸菌が一緒にとれる
で
えーっと付もレスの代替旬の野菜になるので旬の野菜は栄養価も高い
それとまぁたぶん女性喜ばれるんですけどあの
その額ちょっとつまんでこう塗ってもらってあたらえばいいんですけどすごくツヤツヤ
になりますのでぜひ試してみてください
皆さんのぬか床は何して混ぜないといけないとか
の手がかかるとか
そういうイメージがあると思うんですけど今はどのカテには冷蔵庫がありますので冷蔵
庫は活用した時短料理の一つだと思ってもらえれば凄く取り入れやすい
なると思います
でへ最初に
プレゼンターの方が宮崎には何もないと
思われている方がいるという話がありましたが宮崎県には冒頭に出た
大根やぐらがあります
この大根やぐらは宮崎
住んでいる人は当たり前に見える風景ですけど
これはあの他の県議では鹿児島に一部見られるだけです
大根やぐらはあの
かかっている風景見たことあると思うんですけど
一つずつちょっとずつのこの子が手渡しでかけていきます
だいたい星上がるのに2週間かかるんですけどその間雨が降った時にはこのレシートを
かけ
これは
雨が降り始めた時にかけ
シート上げますので夜中に触れば夜中に入っ
あげたままにしておくとあの太陽の熱であの
温室のようになって葉っぱが腐ってしまうので雨が上がったらすぐに下ろす
それが
昼夜問わず農家さんの苦労で
あるがこの腰代行になっています
で宮崎に住んでいる方は
暖かいだけではない宮崎もご存知だと思います
寒いときにはストーブを焚きます
もちろん寒いの夜ですから夜にやぐらに泊まり込みで遠いを継ぎ足しつつ
第肛門を凍らせないように
のが農家さんの
大変な苦労の上に出来上がるのがを次第これ
これがキレイに落ち県内
真っ白に仕上がるのが条坊してはれる干大根なんですが
やはり天気には勝てずに貼りこれがこのような色でなくてプロっぽくなってしまう時も
ので出来るだけ農家の人は
プロをしつつ大根の面倒を見る
このことを太鼓の子守と言っていい
子どもを育てるように日々日々
の管理をしています
でこれはの宮崎県の職員会センターさんが調べてくれた
へ
アミノ酸の成分の一つやば
それの増加状況のグラフです
一番6講座はだ生大根の状態の時の
アミノ酸の分析です
2番目が1週間目
で一番こちらの黄色の色が
干し上がりまあ収穫前で2週間だと思う
こうやってみるとあのアミノ酸がぐんぐん増えているのが
分かってもらえると思う
昔からの天日出すうま味が増すとか
おいしくなるというのはもここに裏付けされている
特にまあ java の状況所増加状況と書きましたけど gaba が特に増えて
いる
これはの gaba が多いと言われるはずが現場に10倍の量です
で gaba というのは中枢神経とかを和らげる効果があるので
その効果として血圧を下げたりという効果も今
研究段階で今ラット試験人間の試験まで出てて
血圧降下作用が今
期待されています
漬物を食べると血圧が上がるというそういうイメージから
宮崎の節大根は血圧を下げる効果が
期待できる要素がありますよということが今わかっています
干し大根が入荷している風景ですね
冒頭の脳がでも出ましたがこれが今ものを
の家でつけている漬物の風景です
あの事務所にも飾ってあるんですが何年前の写真です糧を得ることもあるんですけど今
もこのスタイルデー
大根を
並べて
俺はの隙間なく並べるのがポイントですどの漬物をつける場合もそうなんですけど空気
にできるだけ触れないように高密着させてきれいに並べるのが美味しく作るコツ
うちの場合はムカデしっかりつけるということで国産の込めるかとメキシコ産があり
ますけど自然の結晶天日塩とかこういうもので
漬け込みます
で出来上がったのが
これですね
ない今は資料になぜ黄色いた君は黄色の花っている学校です
熟成発酵すると尻尾のからだんだん黄色くなのが沢庵なんです
ですからあの私個人的には
真っ白な大根よりも
黄色く発行者代行のが
美味しそうに見えませ
で実際あの発行している証拠なので甘みも増してて美味しい
えっとぬか漬けにした場合の
これもあみなさんの分析の数値なんですけどちょっとこれはあの子車
うちだけのものなのでちょっと日ができず分かりづらいかと思うんですけれども
特にグルタミン酸ギャバこの辺が数字が多いのを分かってもらえると思います
ということで
えっと私はこの
漬物の文化
ぬか漬けの文化こういうものが
皆さんもしかしたら難しくて私には出来ないとか
面倒くさそうとか手間がかかりそうとか思っている方もいらっしゃるかもしれませんが
そうではなくて手軽に使用だけでできる
料理方法の一つとしてぜひ皆さんに取り入れていただきたいと思う
その際
やり方がわからないとか
もっとやってみたいけどどうしたらいいんだろうという方は是非その
対する
人の一人として活
約できればなと思っ
[拍手]